hello and welcome to this video
another white weird got one against
legal like small steps towards 2500
losing losing a game is always extremely
costly some typically quite a huge
favorite rating wise that's very ads
very what's the right word very much
focused on one equality it's it's okay
this is how you play it with with black
or you can oh you can play it let's see
you don't have to do it so not even sure
that I played this right don't really
want the Queen on edge forward maybe my
d4 move was not timed all that well
Queeny fault I would be really really
trying to track Queens I don't don't
think that will happen maybe you can do
something interesting on the Queen no
let's try to make C 5 and D 5 more
difficult
I'm not yet so sure if I put my bishop
on to d3 or f3 f3 is Paul name probably
better
yeah my queen on h4 is just so awkwardly
placed okay try to try to use them
slight space advantage that have n2 two
bishops it's not going to be easy to
make something something concrete out of
it but it's very typical position for
this opening line
okay so just want to be ready for the
pawn pushes I know the bishop looks on
only one but you can always reposition
it
okay mmmm I wonder
yeah I think thanks he for his okay I
wasn't so sure but Bishop takes b2
doesn't really do much this is this is
okay do to them completely symmetrical
pawn structure black should be okay even
though I have the two bishops and a half
more space my ideas before b5 which is
still I'm asking some questions so we'll
see how he what defensive setup he
chooses the good thing about this
general position type that we had a
couple of months ago like IKEA it's very
it's very hard for whitey to to lose at
him it's really difficult you need to
make some some pretty strong some pretty
serious mistakes yeah
this is probably yeah probably
blundering sir it's been way jinxing
it's like saying it's hard to lose I
came so he wants to play Knight c3 check
ok I take d5 he takes that I take a 6
play rugby 6 and I win their porn huh
I'm missing something
he doesn't have rope d6 because of this
should be form a bishop you are doing a
good job they're covering the airport
so I had a bit of pressure them it's not
like this is coming completely out of
the blue
that's it's interesting I take it a six
huh if I take on B five a six
we should default a [ __ ] this
eligible to take six he just about gets
there okay
so where to do where to put this
probably here III is a good square
covered by the F pawn and it will help
to push the pawn up to a seven okay okay
okay okay with the check first you know
that check first me
now I'm ready to play a six I overlooked
Bishop takes g3 not sure how much of a
problem that was
no promoting shorty
you know this is this is a super
standard position that you get out of
the two nights variation of the Carol
over time black has surrendered the
bishop here and in return he get this
super solid structure with ecigs and c6
yeah I always wonder what blacks plan is
to ever win probably there is no but you
are
yeah you just sitting there and hope
that why does not getting anywhere with
the payoff bishops and oftentimes this
will be the case you know I mean it's
not like white wins this kind of
position all the time but you can try I
mean here I have fixed some points on
light squares and okay g3 is simple but
important you don't want Bishop f4 and
no trades and now am page form and B
should be one that is also kind of
typical and now he has to think he v or
D or C 5 C 5 is not good probably
because that makes maybe should be even
more effective and he ultimately decided
to play e5 okay so take take and now I
went c4 this is I think a critical
moment in this game what what he should
do the next couple of moves is important
I think this is not good I just take and
I felt here should be clearly better the
King stops the pawn and I get to attack
with the bishop soon I'm surprised that
the engine basically says I'm winning I
thought I'm better and not
not that much yeah okay it's clear that
White's bad of it I wasn't sure that it
is that much okay and here
now I'm how to play b4 b5 and well
you're still defending with black now
you're just sitting there by now it gets
really critical here one point something
taketake actually the the engine gives
the the line of the game and I think
this lost is lost
I should technically be lost what is
interesting can I win worth taking yeah
I kind of thought it should be but I
couldn't quite make it work this a
bishop bishop c3 is the king oops I'm
sorry about that it's the key move I
didn't didn't see that him and now I can
start to take things or play play this
even you know that is right yeah so I
should I should just start taking taking
the Kings side and again I'm getting a
quick pass on yeah as well okay but this
is this should also win it it takes a
bit of time but it should be raining i
blundered bishop g3m i don't think it
matters that much honestly I would have
just continued here without the pawn
okay six fish a Bishop c5 is actually
good yeah okay okay
yeah and the way it was I don't think
there was anything special happening I'm
just winning with the prawns with the
pawn
you know yeah here there's no way to
stop the air porn okay guys thanks for
watching